I'm never going to get this done on time.
Come on! Of course you are.
No, I'm not.
I've barely scratched the surface.
This is going to take forever.
Nothing takes forever.
Just put your mind on it and it'll be finished before you know it.
I wish I could be as optimistic as you, but I can't.
My boss is going to kill me!
No, he's not.
He won't have any reason to because you're going to do a great job on it.
Get real! Here, just take a look at all this.
Let's see ... yeah, it's a lot of work, but you can get it done.
I've seen you do it before.
That was before. This is now.
This is a monumental project.
Well, you know,...
...you're not helping yourself out by talking about it.
Just start doing it!
All right, I guess you're right.
But you've got to help me find a new job after I get canned from this one.